Speaker 1: You know how the right is about small
government and not getting government involved in
stuff unless it's absolutely necessary. Well,
it turns out that's not really true. Multiple
Republicans are now demanding hearings over Direct
TV, dropping the right wing channel, Newsmax. Now,
if you didn't hear about this, what happened is as
follows Companies exist that make decisions. One
of those companies is DirecTV. The David Pakman
Show is on DirecTV. We're on a channel called Free
Speech TV. I believe it's Channel 348 on DirecTV.
Although it might be nine for one five and we're
on 348 on Dish, I don't remember. Anyway, we're
on DirecTV on free speech TV. DirecTV could decide
we don't want free speech TV anymore. They could
decide that for any reason. They could decide that
because free speech TV is left wing or because
they don't like my face or whatever. Right.
DirecTV could decide that they're a company that
can make decisions as long as those decisions are
not illegal based on some narrow regulation that
exists. Well, DirecTV is deciding they're going to
drop Newsmax now. Why are they doing it? I don't
know. Is it because Newsmax is right wing? Maybe
that would be their right? Is it because people
aren't watching Newsmax on DirecTV? Maybe. Is it
because they want to replace it with Golf Channel
number seven? Maybe they can do that. And this is
a private business making a business decision the
way Republicans always say is what should happen.
Not anymore. Let's start with our first
clip. Here is Senator Rick Scott saying
we need congressional hearings into
this. By the way, do you realize what's
going on with health care and climate and
education and the debt ceiling? And this
is what we need congressional hearings about.
Speaker 3: And if anyone knows how to balance
the budget, it's you. You were the governor
of Florida for quite some time. And so I know
that the House will be thankful to have you help
them with ideas. I ask you about this. We've had
about 40 of your colleagues in the House sent
a letter to AT&T and direct warning of hearings
and demanding to know why conservative platforms
like ourselves are being censored and pushed off
of their for their lineup. What would you say to
that? And are there efforts in the Senate to try
to dig into why they're censoring conservatives?
Speaker 2: Absolutely. We're going to get to the
bottom of this is censorship by companies like
AT&T of Conservative Voices. What Google does,
what Facebook does.
Speaker 1: Remember?
So God is people. This is called the firehose of
falsehoods. It's not censorship for companies to
decide what channels they want to carry. Sometimes
I might like the decisions, and sometimes I might
not. It is not censorship. Secondly, we just had
a study that revealed the claims about Google's
bias are untrue. There have been studies
about Facebook's bias, and it found actually
conservative political content is usually the best
performing stuff on Facebook. He just squeezed
three lies into 5 seconds and people watch this
stuff and they go, He's probably right, you know?
Speaker 2: You watch we watch what Elon Musk has
put out about when Twitter did. This has got to
stop. So we need to we need to hold hearings
here. We need to get the bottom of this. I'm
going to do everything I can. They already got
rid of another conservative network earlier or
sometime last year. Now, now Newsmax. Is
this what they're trying to do? They're
trying to shut down our voices and we've got
to fight for this. The American public have
to show up. So so if you're watching, call AT&T.
Speaker 1: Say you can call an AT&T and tell them
you want Newsmax. Absolutely, you can do that.
But congressional hearings using the power of
government to investigate cable lineups, satellite
TV lineups. Congressman Michael Waltz says there
should be congressional hearings as well.
Speaker 2: 41 members of Congress have have
signed this. I've got it right here. Letter to
DirecTV calling calling on them to to address
this. Your name is on that list. Where does that
go from here? Something like, you know, a letter
like this that you send to to the people that
run Direct TV and AT&T. What happens after that?
Well, you know, we have a number of questions in
that letter that will demand answers for you. It
could go so far as to have their executives
come to talk to us and explain this to us.
Speaker 1: Why did you get rid of the show?
Is it because you don't like the look of Sean
Spicer suits on Newsmax? Tell us the truth.
Speaker 2: In terms of that, both the timing
and the intent and it could go as far as.
Speaker 1: Is. The timing doesn't matter
and the intent doesn't matter. They are free to
decide what channels to have public hearings.
Speaker 2: But I think the public hearings
should be part of this broader effort. And,
you know, from the left to essentially
snap everybody in line with their view,
their way of thinking or you can't get
access to anything, you need to actually
function as a company or a business.
Speaker 1: Yeah, well, listen,
as you can tell, Republicans taking over
the House has immediately put them laser
focused on the issues most important to the
American people. Oh, wait, no, it's actually
not. Here's one more. Here's Congressman Jeff
Van Drew saying we need to do hearings before
there aren't any conservative voices left.
Speaker 2: No question about it. And it's
not self-indulgent because the bottom line is.
Speaker 1: What he means is it is self-indulgent.
Speaker 2: What this country is about
is freedom of ideas, freedom of vision.
Speaker 1: Which applies to DirectTV DirecTV as
freedom of ideas to determine what they want on
their network. DirecTV has freedom of vision to
determine how they want their network to play out.
Speaker 2: Freedom of discussion, freedom
of speech. And I would be angry if they
were secretly doing that to a liberal. Sure you
would. A group of people or a liberal, you know,
magazine or a liberal newspaper or anybody that
represented one side or the other. The point is,
we should be able to have our viewpoints and
they should be able to be expressed. In this
particular case, it's real obvious something's
wrong because there are stations that are on
Direct TV that don't do as well as you. There
are stations that are on Direct TV that don't.
Speaker 1: It sounds like the Republican here
is saying Direct TV should use the metrics
he thinks should be used to decide. Why does
DirecTV have to decide about channel lineups
based on what is most viewed that? That's for the
government to tell DirecTV. That's how you have
to decide is extraordinary overreach. I can't
even continue with this nonsense because it's
so crazy. Listen to the bottom line of what's
going on here. They claim that they are against
government regulation. They don't want government
overreaching. Government should stay out of stuff
unless absolutely necessary, except all of a
sudden they want government to force Twitter
to publish COVID disinformation and all of
a sudden they want government to direct the
conversations and decisions made by doctors
and women in medical settings about abortion.
And they want government to decide what types of
sex are legal. Talk about sodomy laws here. The
way Ken Paxton recently said would be completely
defensible in Texas for Texas to do. They love the
free market until the free market dumps them.
DirecTV wants to dump Newsmax and they can do
that. Will this fix inflation? No. They claim that
that's a real issue, which, by the way, has been
coming down for months. Will this fix the issue
of the debt or whatever else? All this stuff?
Will anyone get health care as a result of this?
Of course not. These people are pathetic and
they are dangerous. And this is the type of stuff
unfortunately, many Republicans have elected them
to do. They want them doing this sort of thing.
It's sad, but it is not altogether surprising.